we've got some breaking news out of
Israel and that is that the Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu who has
fired his defense minister of a calling
for a halt to a Judicial overhaul now
the defense minister eurov Gallant broke
ranks Yesterday by publicly urging
Benjamin Netanyahu to suspend the
legislation that would do give that
overhaul of the judicial system for a
month so pause it and he said that the
Countrywide protests against the
overhaul
were also affecting regular forces and
undermining National Security because
they had included a growing number of
military reservists um Mr galancing I
will not facilitate this he said it was
a very short statement on TV and he
hinted that should the ratification vote
be held this week that he might abstain
so the latest news out of Israel is that
Benjamin Netanyahu has fired the defense
minister joab gallant and that was after
Mr Gallant called on the prime minister
to Halt what are controversial plans for
an overhaul of the justice system
now his invention comes as Israelis
opposed to the changes held Mass rallies
again across the country this is the
12th week in a row that they have held
those let's go to Jerusalem now and
speak to Alistair bunkel who is on the
phone uh bring us up to date Alistair
well there's been rumors throughout the
day that Benjamin Netanyahu now that
he's back in Israel after spending a few
days over the weekend in London uh would
remove his defense minister you have
Gallant from that position after Gallant
last night came out publicly
and said that he thought there should be
a halt in the process of the very
controversial judicial reforms he was
the most senior member of netanyahu's
coalition to speak out against the
judicial reforms he was backed by a
number of other Coalition politicians as
well
Netanyahu has decided to fire him from
his post now I think there's a couple of
uh interesting
consequences from this firstly what will
it mean for those within netanyahu's
party who might privately or publicly
have
reservations about these judicial
reforms will it Harden their opinions
and will it perhaps convince them that
they now need to vote against the net
and Yahoo government
secondly there is two fronts in the
Israeli government are fighting on at
the moment and the other one is of
course the growing tensions in the West
Bank Ramadan is now a few days underway
and these coming weeks are being seen as
a really crucial period for the security
of Israel and the west bank and to
remove the defense minister the
politician who oversees the Israeli
Defense Forces at this moment is not
without its risks so this is a move
taken by Netanyahu in order to try and
Shore up his support to push through
these reforms which he's going to try
and do at PACE this week before the
Israeli Parliament breaks for the
Passover recess but protests against it
are growing bigger and bigger they're a
protests tonight outside many of the
politicians homes later this week
there'll be a massive protest in the
um outside the knesset in Jerusalem and
Netanyahu has his back against the wall
and there are cracks showing him his
coalition
um so what does this mean for his future
then if he his back is against the wall
and this is the latest move what's it
going to mean for his future
well I mean it really is a good question
and there are a number of paths that
this
um could go down and it's really hard to
predict at the moment what we can say
for certainty is that Netanyahu despite
the opposition within the Israeli public
is determined to carry on with these
judicial reforms and just to recap for
those people who aren't necessarily
aware of what it means it changes the
way that judges to the Supreme Court
will be elected and it will give an
awful lot more power to the government
of the day uh to push through any rules
and laws that they want to do so and it
will remove a lot of oversight uh that
the Supreme Court currently has and that
is why so many Israelis believe what is
happening is a dramatic erosion of
Israeli democracy and so that is the
kind of the conflict the political
conflicts the society the societal
conflict you've got going on in Israel
at the moment
Yahoo is a prime minister for the sixth
term in office and he is leading
Israel's most far-right government in
Israel's history and there are a number
of far-right politicians in his
government
who believe very strongly in changing
the ways of Judiciary is formed and
using it to potentially push for
greater presence in the West Bank for
example greater rights for Ultra
Orthodox Jews and they at the moment
seem to have the loudest voices and many
commentators wonder how Benny Netanyahu
who is generally considered to be a very
widely politician a pretty popular
politician up until recently in Israel
but how he can maneuver his way out of
this because it's hard to see
how there is any good solution for
either side
okay Alistair bunkel for us in Jerusalem
thank you so much for that update
Alistair and just to reiterate
What's Happening Here Benjamin Netanyahu
the Israeli Prime Minister has fired his
defense minister there comes a day after
the defense minister yo of Gallant
called for a halt to what has planned a
planned overhaul of the country's
Judiciary it has divided the country
there have been no further details from
Mr netanyahu's office and Mr Gallant
he's a former Army General he is a
senior member of Benjamin netanyahu's
ruling liquid party so Benjamin
Netanyahu the Israeli Prime Minister
firing his defense minister tonight